[Music]
is taking dancing with the devil
to a whole other level
the 21 year old rapper dropped the music
video for his new single montero
call me by your name and it is truly a
fantastical adventure
the video which lil nas co-directed is
filled with many biblical and ancient
greek references
including a seductive half-snake
half-human in
[Music]
a shackled up lil nas then finds himself
at execution day in a coliseum
where he is surrounded and receives
judgment from versions of himself
a dime in a nine it was mine every week
what a time an incline god was shining
on me
now i can't leave and now we're making
it and once he's executed he goes down
the pole to hell
to seduce the devil himself
[Music]
lil nas send some love to all the
hard-working pole dancers out there
revealing on twitter that his legs were
bleeding on set
lil nas also opened up about the
significance of his latest song
by sharing an emotional letter he wrote
his younger self
about coming out as gay he started out
writing
dear fourteen-year-old montero which is
his birth name
i know we promise to never come out
publicly i know we promise
to never be that type of gay person i
know we promise to die with the secret
but this will open doors for many other
queer people to simply
exist in lil naz's opening voice over in
the music video
he also shares that he's done hiding his
true authentic self
in life we hide the parts of ourselves
we don't want the world to see
we lock them away we tell them no
we banished them but here
we don't welcome to montero there's
been so much growth like beyond just you
know the fame and fortune like mentally
spiritually i've grown so much the new
song has already received
lots of love from little nazex fans and
his celebrity pals like miley cyrus
who posted herself listening to the bop
and sent lil nas flowers to celebrate
and even more touching the georgia
native also got the stamp of approval
from his dad
sharing a screenshot of a text message
that says live life
on your terms very proud of you i called
it badges today
you hit me with a car to your place
ain't been out in the wall anyway
was hoping i could catch you throwing
smiles in my face and it won't be long
until we get even more new music from
lil nazex
the rapper also revealed his new album
also called montero
will drop this summer i'm like in a in a
constant state of
you know realization and like just like
life in general how everything is
happening for me and just
and then you know just grateful overall
[Music]
me